.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich bin 30 und bettlägerig.
Wenn Leute fragen, wie ich das
mache, weiss ich nicht, was sagen.
Ich habe halt keine Wahl.
(Frau) Jeder Tag
ist eine Riesenherausforderung.
Der Tag hat mehr Stunden,
als man wach bleiben mag,
wenn man stundenlang liegen
und all die Symptome ertragen muss.
Als wäre man von einem Lastwagen
überfahren worden.
Nervenschmerzen,
Muskelschmerzen, Gewebeschmerzen.
Alles tut weh.
Es geht jeden Tag so weiter.
Monat für Monat, Jahr für Jahr.
Es
ist ein so unvorstellbares Leiden.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das in Worte fassen kann.
Au.
Ein Albtraum für Betroffene -
ME/CFS, Myalgische Enzephalomyelitis,
das chronische Fatigue-Syndrom.
Ruf an, wenn etwas ist.
- Mhm.
Bis später.
Cassandra Helfer aus Thun:
Vor 13 Jahren
ist sie an ME/CFS erkrankt.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute?
Das ist im Moment
noch etwas schwierig zu sagen.
Wenn ich aufwache, ist mir jeweils
direkt schwindlig und schlecht.
Ich kriege Herzrasen
und meine Glieder sind wie tot.
Und ich habe so ein ekelhaftes
Gefühl in den Muskeln.
Eine Schwäche.
Der Körper
ist einfach noch nicht wach.
Okay. Ich lasse Sie.
ME ist eine chronische körperliche,
eine neuroimmunologische Erkrankung.
Die Batterien von Betroffenen wie der
29-jährigen Cassandra Helfer sind -
bildlich gesprochen -
nie mehr voll aufgeladen
und entladen sich rasend schnell.
Viele denken,
das habe einen psychischen Ursprung
und dass man nicht wolle.
Ja ...
- Das ist aber nicht so, oder?
Man solle an die frische Luft gehen
und dann sei es wieder gut.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
- Sie können nicht.- Ja.
Wenn ich könnte,
wäre ich über alle Berge.
Aber ich bin
wie in meinem Körper gefangen.
Von der Psyche her, von dem, was ich
möchte, wäre es etwas ganz anderes.
ME/CFS
bricht oft nach einem Infekt aus,
von dem sich die Betroffenen
nie mehr erholen.
Bei Cassandra Helfer
war es das Pfeiffersche Drüsenfieber,
an dem sie mit 16 erkrankte.
Ich mache das Licht im Bad
meistens gar nicht an.
Es ist zu hell.
Und die Lüftung geht dann an,
was ich auch nicht vertrage.
Jetzt ist es ja hell,
aber abends ...
Dafür haben wir hier eine Lampe ...
... installiert.
Das Zähneputzen war etwas
vom Ersten, das mir aufgefallen ist.
Dass ich dabei
immer Pause machen musste.
Und ...
Es fehlte irgendwie
die Kraft zum Zähneputzen.
Irgendwann
wurde mir dann schwindlig.
Dann musste ich mich hinsetzen
und zeitweise musste ich mich sogar
hinlegen, um die Zähne zu putzen.
Es ist irgendwie ...
Zu ME wurde bisher kaum geforscht.
Vermutet wird,
dass die Energiegewinnung
in der Zelle beeinträchtigt ist.
Im Blut
oder mit bildgebenden Verfahren
kann die Erkrankung
nicht diagnostiziert werden.
Hinzu kommt: Viele Mediziner
kennen die Krankheit nicht.
Daraus resultieren jahrelange, kraft-
raubende Odysseen von Arzt zu Arzt.
Nach zehn Jahren, in denen es hiess,
es könnte psychisch sein ...
... war es
eine riesige Erleichterung ...
... endlich
einen Namen dafür zu haben.
Einfach zu wissen,
mit was ich es zu tun habe.
Man zweifelt auch an sich selbst.
Innerlich
läuft ein riesiger Prozess ab.
Ich bin auch sehr dankbar
für mein Umfeld,
das mir den Rücken gestärkt hat.
Ich zweifelte natürlich
immer wieder an mir:
"Bilde ich mir das ein?"
Das ist so diffus.
ME beeinträchtigt das zentrale
und autonome Nervensystem,
das Immunsystem und den Stoffwechsel:
Hirnnebel, Muskelschwäche
oder Magen-Darm-Beschwerden
sind einige weitere
der unzähligen Symptome.
Jetzt macht der Kreislauf
nicht mehr mit.
Nur wenige Kilometer
von Cassandra Helfer entfernt,
in Heimberg, lebt Dejan Lauber.
Auch er ist an ME erkrankt.
Ich kenne Dejan Lauber
nur von seinen Sprachnachrichten
und sehe ihn heute zum ersten Mal.
Telefonieren oder Vorgespräche -
zu kräfteraubend für ihn.
Guten Tag, Frau Arnet.
Freitag ist gut.
Wir machen es so:
Kommen Sie in den zweiten Stock
und ich lasse
die Eingangstüre einen Spalt offen.
Sie können einfach reinkommen.
Sobald die Begrüssung durch ist,
stelle ich den Timer
auf 20 Min. ein.
Wieso?
Damit es
nicht zu viel auf einmal wird.
Damit der Besuch
nicht zu anstrengend wird?
Damit Sie mich
quasi rauswerfen können?
Ja, genau. Damit es
nicht zu viel am Stück wird.
Was würde passieren,
wenn wir länger bleiben würden?
Und miteinander sprechen oder so?
Wenn es eine Überanstrengung gibt,
müsste ich ...
... mit einer verzögerten Ver-
schlechterung der Symptome rechnen.
Das startet meistens
am nächsten Tag.
Was sind Ihre schlimmsten Symptome?
Bei mir ist das
eine körperliche Schwäche.
Die macht alles ganz schwer.
Und Schmerzen.
- Schmerzen?
Wie muss man sich
diese Schmerzen vorstellen?
Wenn ich versuche,
das zu beschreiben ...
Es ist so,
als würden die Muskeln brennen,
als stünden sie in Flammen.
Können Sie
gar nicht mehr selber gehen?
Nein,
das braucht zu viel Anstrengung.
Ich verkrafte
weder Aufrechtstehen noch Gehen.
Die Schwäche ist wahrscheinlich
mehr als die Müdigkeit,
die wir Gesunden haben, oder?
- Ähm ...
Ja, es fühlt sich ganz anders an
als das, was ich früher unter ...
... Müdigkeit oder Schwäche
verstand.
Ähm ...
Es ist eine tiefgreifende Schwäche.
Es ist nicht so, als könnte man ...
Ähm ...
... sich kurz hinlegen
und es wird besser.
Sehe ich das richtig,
dass Sie Mühe haben, Worte zu finden?
Ja, das ist auch ein Teil davon.
Das ...
Mein Gehirn
funktioniert etwas langsamer.
Dejan Laubers gesamtes Leben
spielt sich in den zwei Zimmern
seiner Wohnung ab,
die er seit vier Jahren
nicht mehr verlassen kann.
"Go and Explore" -
rausgehen und die Welt entdecken?
Das habe ich früher oft gemacht.
Eine gute Erinnerung.
- Sind Sie viel gereist?
Ich erinnere mich immer daran,
dass es ...
... draussen ...
... jeden Tag schön ist
und sein wird.
* Piepsen *
Jetzt ist es Zeit zu gehen.
Sie werfen mich raus.
Ja, das wäre ... würde mir ...
- Gut.
Gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ade.
- Ade.
Würde ich nur noch ein paar Minuten
länger bleiben,
hätte Dejan Lauber keine Energie mehr
zum Kauen seiner Mahlzeiten,
für Toilettengänge oder Körperpflege.
So wie Dejan Lauber
und Cassandra Helfer
geht es weltweit
geschätzten 17 Mio. Menschen.
Die internationale Bewegung
"MillionsMissing"
kämpft für Anerkennung,
medizinische und soziale Versorgung
der Betroffenen
sowie für ein Vorantreiben
der ME/CFS-Forschung.
#MillionsMissing.
Wir vermissen das Leben
und wir vermissen,
daran teilnehmen zu können.
Und wir werden
von unseren Angehörigen vermisst.
Wir können halt
viel nicht dabei sein.
Es ist megatraurig zu sehen,
wie viele Betroffene es gibt.
So viele Junge und Kinder haben
schon ihr ganzes Leben verpasst.
Und die Situation
ist immer noch gleich.
Seit 1996, als die Erkrankung
bei der WHO klassifiziert wurde.
Und es dürften noch viele
weitere Millionen hinzukommen.
Experten vermuten nämlich,
dass 1 bis 2 %
aller Covid-19-Erkrankten
an Long Covid
und später an ME leiden werden.
Die Symptome der beiden
Krankheiten gleichen sich aufs Haar.
* Schweres Atmen *
ME/CFS betrifft v.a. junge Menschen,
häufig Frauen unter 40 Jahren.
Ärzte und Sozialversicherungen
nehmen ihr Leiden meist nicht ernst.
Ihren Rollstuhl etwa musste sich
Cassandra Helfer selbst finanzieren.
Weil nicht geforscht wird, gibt es
auch noch keine Therapie gegen ME.
Der 29-jährigen Cassandra Helfer
bringt Craniosakraltherapie
manchmal etwas Linderung.
Schwerstbetroffene hingegen
sind vollkommen bettlägerig,
fristen ein Leben
mit unerträglichen Schmerzen,
oft in abgedunkelten
und schallisolierten Räumen,
ernährt mit Magensonden.
Mir ist einfach megaschwindlig.
- Schwindlig? Ja.
Kannst du so? Ah, gut.
Merci vielmals. Mach es gut.
- Gerne.
Tschau, hat mich gefreut.
- Tschüss.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Mein erster Besuch
hat Dejan Lauber zu sehr angestrengt.
Darum schickt er mir
fortan Videobotschaften.
Alle drei Tage schafft er 10 Min.
Die Krankheit
hat mich in dem Sinne verändert ...
... dass man ganz stark merken muss,
wo die Limiten sind.
Bei vielem,
von dem man dachte, man wisse es,
muss man von vorne anfangen.
Dejan Lauber, gelernter Elektroniker,
infizierte sich 2012 in einem
Zivildiensteinsatz auf Madagaskar
mit einem tropischen Erreger,
wovon er sich nie mehr erholte.
Dejan
verschwand aus seinem aktiven Leben.
Er war mit den Leuten unterwegs.
Er hatte Freunde,
eine Partnerin, einen Beruf.
Er hatte die Berufsmatur angefangen.
Er führte
ein gesundes, normales Leben.
Er machte Fallschirmsprünge,
fuhr Motorrad und Ski ...
Er reiste ...
Er war lebendig.
Er war sehr interessiert.
Der Kopf ist ihm ja geblieben.
Einfach der Körper -
und der Kopf, wenn er müde ist -,
macht nicht mehr mit.
Aber sein Wesen ist noch da.
Auch Dejan Lauber
reiste von Arzt zu Arzt
mit einer immer schlimmer werdenden
Muskelschwäche und Schmerzen.
Bei den unzähligen Untersuchungen
schwang stets der Verdacht mit,
dass die Krankheit
psychosomatisch oder nur eingebildet,
Dejan psychisch krank sei.
Einfach so in sich zusammenfallen -
das macht man nicht extra.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie man das machen würde.
Er macht sein Leben kaputt.
Er hatte eine nette Freundin -
die würde er nicht wegschicken.
Das macht man nicht.
Im besten Alter des Lebens,
in voller Gesundheit,
mit glücklicher Beziehung,
guter Familie und gutem Beruf,
Aussicht auf ein Studium -
in dem Moment am wenigsten.
Jonas Zurbriggen kennt
Cassandra Helfer seit sechs Jahren
und musste mit ansehen,
wie seine Freundin
immer schwächer und schwächer wurde.
Ich gehe selber.
Sicher?
- Ich weiss nicht.
* Unverständlich *
Ja, ist gut.
Ein Lift wäre nicht schlecht.
- Ein Lift wäre was.
Geht es oder soll ich dir helfen?
Ja, sonst wird es morgen,
bis ich oben bin.
Du musst loslassen.
- Ich kann nicht.- Sorry.
Willst du ihn behalten?
- Nein, kannst du den Daumen ...
Ja, merci.
So.
* Tiefes Ausatmen *
Ich muss kurz ...
Kannst du kurz loslassen?
So. Machen wir noch einen?
So.
- So.
Merci vielmals.
Setz dich hin.
- Yes.
Grazie mille.
- De nada.
Wenn sie versucht, Staub zu saugen
oder etwas zu machen,
sieht man, dass da ein Traum
und Elan dahintersteckt.
Man sieht, wie motiviert sie wäre.
Man bemerkt ihren Kämpferinstinkt
einfach extrem.
Sie gibt nicht einfach auf.
Das Leben ist nicht vorbei,
weil sie in der Situation ist.
Sie macht das Beste daraus
und schaut nach und nach.
Man nimmt jeden Tag so,
wie er kommt.
Sorry.
Und das?
- Mangiare.
Wir mögen uns halt einfach.
Unsere Beziehung hatte von Anfang an
eine gute Basis.
Würde ich sagen.
Aber es ist nicht immer einfach.
Es gibt natürlich auch Reibereien.
Das ist dann schwierig,
weil ich es manchmal nicht ertrage,
dass er mit mir spricht.
Dann reagiere ich z.B. auch gereizt.
Und auch sonst.
Man möchte ja nicht, dass der
Partner immer überall helfen muss.
Ich muss ja auch für mich kochen
oder für mich waschen.
Jetzt wasche oder koche ich
halt für zwei.
Darum fällt mir das nicht so auf.
Für mich sind das Kleinigkeiten,
wenn ich z.B.
etwas zu trinken geben muss.
Aber sie sagt,
das seien keine Kleinigkeiten.
Aber für mich stimmt es.
Was hast du gemacht?
Hallo, Dejan. Hey, hey.
Schau,
da vorne ist das Fernsehen.
So cool.
- Fangen wir noch mal an?
Hören Sie mich?
Ja.
Willst du den Hund füttern?
Das Hundefutter ist im Schlafzimmer.
Du kannst ihm das bringen.
Das linke Röhrchen.
- Das gibt es ja nicht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Jetzt. Jetzt.
Tomi, nimm es. Bsbsbs.
Ein bisschen die Katze ärgern.
Macht das Spass?
Es ist, als wäre Dejan hier.
Wenn man ihn sieht,
weiss man eigentlich, was er denkt.
Man spürt seine Emotionen
und wie er dabei ist.
Wir sehen, ob er sich freut,
ob er enttäuscht ist,
ob es gelingt oder nicht.
Er zeigt das relativ gut.
Wir brauchen mehr Futter.
* Lachen *
Ich komme mir jeweils so vor,
als wäre ich hier in meiner Wohnung
in einem Gefängnis.
Ich kann sie nicht verlassen.
Ich sah immer gerne Bilder und
Videos von Bekannten und Freunden.
Ich sah mir das immer gerne an.
Da kam mir der Gedanke,
wie es wäre, einen Roboter zu bauen,
mit dem ich dann in Echtzeit
dabei sein könnte.
* Emotionale Musik *
Es gab mir schon sehr viel Freude,
mit dem Roboter
am Leben teilzunehmen
und mit Bekannten
unterwegs sein zu können.
Das hat mir schon gefehlt.
Ich war eigentlich sehr erstaunt,
dass mir das auch ein Gefühl gibt,
wieder teilnehmen zu können.
Es ist eine passive Rolle,
in der man einfach dabei sein kann.
Ohne im Mittelpunkt zu sein
und ohne dass Erwartungen entstehen.
Man kann einfach ein bisschen sein.
Das ist jetzt der zweite Tag
nach dem Drehtag.
Gestern ging es einigermassen.
Aber heute kommt ...
... sozusagen die Quittung.
Alles tut weh. Gut, ich muss ...
... unbedingt aufhören.
Ich hätte erwartet,
dass es heute besser ist.
Jetzt war es noch viel schlimmer.
Auch zweieinhalb Wochen nach
meinem letzten Besuch mit der Kamera
geht es Cassandra Helfer nicht gut.
Symptomverschlimmerung
nach Überanstrengung -
das eindeutigste Symptom von ME.
Je mehr ich rede,
desto mehr Herzrasen bekomme ich.
Und somit immer weniger Luft.
Wenn ich so Herzrasen habe,
geht die Batterie schnell runter.
In den paar Minuten ging die runter?
- Ja.
Aber ...
Ich muss schauen ... Ja, 115.
Sonst nehme ich einen Betablocker.
Das könnte ich kurz machen.
Jetzt habe ich richtig Herzrasen.
Dann fängt alles an ...
... zu zittern.
Und ich kriege keine Luft mehr.
Ist das, weil es zu anstrengend ist,
mir ein Interview zu geben?- Ja.
Jetzt muss ich
meine Heizdecke anstellen.
Die Temperaturregelung
ist nämlich auch betroffen.
Dann fange ich an
zu frieren und zu zittern.
Ja.
Jetzt wird es langsam etwas besser.
Der Puls ist immer noch ...
Ja, wenn ich anfange zu sprechen,
geht er direkt wieder hoch.
Weil so viele Ärzte
ME/CFS nicht kennen,
werden Erkrankte
oft auch falsch therapiert.
Was bei
Burn-out und Depressionen heilt,
ist für ME-Betroffene Gift:
körperliche Aktivierung.
In der Schweiz gibt es leider
noch ein paar Einrichtungen,
die bei ME
Aktivierungstherapie verschreiben.
Wenn man als Patient dorthin
gelangt, sitzt man in der Tinte.
Sie haben ihn
wirklich zum Laufen gezwungen.
Sie schleppten ihn den Gang runter
oder bis zum Bad und zurück.
Dann rühmten sie ihn,
weil er am Schluss
mehr habe laufen mögen.
Es war schlimm, dabei zuzuschauen.
Ich habe den Leuten ...
dieser Klinik geglaubt.
Sie haben mir
Tag für Tag versprochen,
dass ich gesünder werden würde.
Wenn der Aufenthalt
abgeschlossen sei,
könne ich wieder rumlaufen
und wandern gehen usw.
Das war nicht der Fall.
Ich ging im Rollstuhl nach Hause.
Einmal pro Woche
erledigt Peter Lauber
den Einkauf für seinen Sohn Dejan.
Immer am Mittwoch,
immer zur gleichen Uhrzeit.
Er hat seine Pausen,
weil er weiss, dass ich dann komme.
Dann hat er auch 10 Min.,
um mit mir zu sprechen.
Wenn ich zu früh oder spät komme,
habe ich eine Woche lang
nichts von ihm.
Schauen Sie. Wenn er Dinge hat,
die ich nicht kenne,
neue Produkte,
die ich überall suchen muss,
weiss ich, dass es ihm gut geht.
Dann hat er Kraft und hat
im Internet das Sortiment studiert
und bestellt andere Dinge.
Manchmal kommt dieselbe Bestellung
wie vor einer Woche.
Da weiss ich, dass er auf null ist
und Essen braucht.
Er konnte sich nicht
damit beschäftigen, was er möchte.
Das ist schön,
dann suche ich halt länger.
Sauerteigbrot.
Puh.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Wenn ich könnte,
würde ich am liebsten rennen gehen.
Wenn ich wieder gesund
oder fitter bin,
ist das das Erste, was ich mache.
Und ...
Ja.
Der Kontakt zu anderen Leuten
fehlt halt extrem.
Ja, der Plan wäre schon ...
... endlich zu heiraten
und eine Familie zu gründen.
Ist das realistisch?
Wie es im Moment ist, sicher nicht.
Ja.
Ja. Das ist ein bisschen
mein Babyersatz.
Die brauchen auch viel Liebe,
Zeit und Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich finde es
eigentlich schlimmer ...
... was alles mit einem passiert.
Was man sich alles anhören muss
und durch was man sich kämpfen muss.
Die ganze Demütigung eigentlich,
bis man
überhaupt ernstgenommen wird.
Es ist eben
nicht nur eine junge Frau,
die dem Leben nicht gewachsen ist.
Jetzt habe ich den Faden verloren.
- Jetzt ist das Hirn wieder müde.
Hey, Dejan,
ich sehe dich noch nicht wirklich.
Ich bringe dir ein Buch zurück.
Ein paar Grissini und eine Suppe.
Ich stelle sie hier hin.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute, Herr Lauber?
- Heute ist es ganz okay.
Eigentlich
möchte ich ganz leise sein ...
... damit ich keine Geräusche mache
und ihn der Lärm nicht stört.
Das ist auch eine Belastung für ihn.
Aber manchmal knallt es
beim Aufmachen oder so halt doch.
Ich beeile mich jeweils, weil ich
lieber etwas mit ihm spreche ...
... als zu lange dafür zu brauchen.
Wen sehen Sie noch alles?
In Person
habe ich nicht viel Besuch.
Nur meinen Vater,
meine Mutter und die Postboten.
Und die Coiffeuse.
Ich stelle es mir
unendlich schwierig vor,
sein eigenes Kind
in dem Zustand sehen zu müssen.
Ja.
Wir können nur zuschauen.
Das ist schwierig für uns.
Er muss leiden und das durchmachen.
Ich habe oft gesagt,
dass ich mit ihm tauschen würde.
Oder es wenigstens mit ihm teilen.
Halbe-halbe. Hm?
Aber das geht nicht.
Ja, ja.
Du magst nicht mehr. Dann gehe ich.
Hm?
Tschüss.
Bis bald. Schreib mir.
- Mhm.
Meistens
kann ich mich zusammenreissen
und weine dann
von hier bis nach Hause.
(Weinend) Das geht einem so nahe.
Im Gegensatz zu Dejan Lauber
bekam Cassandra Helfer
keine Rente von der IV zugesprochen.
Die Fachfrau Gesundheit
arbeitete weiter in ihrem Beruf,
bis es nicht mehr ging.
Heute lebt Cassandra Helfer
von der Sozialhilfe.
Man schätzt, dass in der Schweiz
zwischen 16'000 und 24'000
ME-Betroffene leben.
Viele von ihnen ohne IV-Rente,
in Armut wie Cassandra Helfer.
Wir haben
absolut vergleichbare Fälle -
der eine kriegt eine,
der andere nicht.
Man könnte
auch um die Rente würfeln.
Schwer krank zu sein,
ist schlimm genug.
Aber wenn noch Armut
und Einsamkeit dazukommen,
ist es noch um einiges schlimmer.
Um Erkrankten
rechtlichen Beistand zu leisten,
stellen Jonas Sagelsdorff
und Rechtsanwalt Thomas Hueber
eine Anlaufstelle für ME-Erkrankte
auf die Beine.
Prima.
Die Gutachter verkennen,
dass die Symptome der Erkrankung
sich nach körperlichen, geistigen
oder emotionalen Anstrengungen
verschlimmern können.
Das ist ein Teil
des Krankheitsbildes.
In den Gutachten liest man dann,
es sei alles tipptopp,
man wisse nicht,
was die Person habe.
Die Gutachter haben den Tag danach
nicht als Vergleichszeitpunkt.
Sie sehen nicht,
wie es der Person danach geht.
Um ein besseres Verständnis
für die Krankheit publik zu machen,
braucht es eine interdisziplinäre
Zusammenarbeit.
Nur wenn die Betroffenen, die Ärzte,
die Sozial-
bzw. die Invalidenversicherung
und nötigenfalls auch die Juristen
zusammenarbeiten,
kann man dem komplexen
Krankheitsbild gerecht werden.
(Flüsternd) Hallo.
- Guten Tag.
Mein letzter Besuch bei Dejan Lauber.
Er legt mir
sein wichtigstes Anliegen ans Herz.
Dass es
in der Forschung vorwärtsgeht.
Dass die Gesellschaft
die Krankheit sieht ...
... und auch angeht.
Mir geht es seit ...
... mehreren Tagen
zunehmend schlechter.
Es wurde so schlimm, dass ich
eine Kortisoninfusion brauchte.
Es fühlt sich
schon etwas tragisch an.
Als würde man sterben.
* Schweres Schlucken *
Cassandra Helfer
geht es zusehends schlechter.
Sie hat Lähmungserscheinungen,
kann nicht mehr sprechen.
Oft erholen sich die Betroffenen
nicht mehr
von solchen Zusammenbrüchen.
Die Symptome
verschlimmern sich irreversibel.
Da ist schon
die Angst im Hinterkopf ...
... ob das immer so bleibt.
Wird der Rest meines Lebens
so aussehen?
Jeden Tag so,
immer wieder warten und hoffen,
dass der nächste besser wird?
Ja ... Das ist ...
... nicht schön.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Zum geplanten letzten Dreh
an Cassandras Lieblingsplatz
erscheint ihr Freund Jonas allein.
Cassandra fehlt. Einmal mehr.
Einen so wunderschönen Ausblick
möchte man mit jemandem teilen.
Sie fehlt.
Ich möchte, dass sie das auch sieht.
Das fehlt mir.
Ja. Diese Augenblicke,
die man miteinander teilt.
ME - Myalgische Enzephalomyelitis.
Die Krankheit
verursacht unsägliches Leid.
Und sie macht arm, einsam
und lässt Menschen verschwinden.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022